Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go and take a look at the material editor
and parent materials by starting out taking a look at the interface and how to organize
your workflows as well as looking at the interface later on and we're going to look at material
editors and how to work with instance materials and how that whole system lines up.
So let's get started.
So you'll see in the material editor overview window we have many things to look at here
and this can get a little bit daunting so we're going to jump into Unreal and I'm going
to walk you through some of these things.
Once we do that we're going to talk a bit about organizing and then we'll make a have
another video for you in which we'll look at making a parent material and then working
with those nodes and then creating an instance material.
Let's go and dive right into Unreal and take a peek.
So let's go ahead and I'm going to pick on this particular material here.
So in this material you'll see that we have an instance material.
Now typically by default what happens is let's go ahead and go to the parent material first
and let's double click on this instance material and you'll see with this instance material
open, let me pull it over to off screen, you'll see that we have a parent material.
Now you're probably wondering what is an instance material?
It is a child of a parent material.
It's inheriting all the aspects of the parent material but encapsulated in such a way we
can quickly make changes without having to recompile the texture.
And what I mean by that is I can go in here and change my albedo intensity, I can change
my albedo color if I wish, like hitting that tick box on and I can change all different
types of aspects if they're open as in the parameters are open to be able to be changed
in the parent material and I can then do so in the instance material.
And it gives you a quick and efficient way to change things the way that you need without
having to recompile.
So I'm quickly just changing the normal intensity here and you can see it change on the fly in
3D and it's pretty cool, pretty nice to be able to work like this.
So let me go and set these back to default.
And let's go to the parent material.
In the parent material, let's talk about what we're looking at here because there's a lot
to unpack and I want you guys to understand all the tools at your disposal.
Number one we can see that we have over here on the left is our viewer.
Now this viewer gives us a quick preview of what our material is going to look like in
our final output.
If you ever want to change the lighting and you want to check the normal roughness or
spec, you can keep your finger on the L key and you can left mouse click and get that
to update just by moving your mouse around.
You'll see here you can choose if you wanted to epic headquarters, which we have, which
is fine, or just gray wireframe.
It's up to you.
We'll leave it at epic headquarters, but we can show things just like we would normally
with unreal here in the viewer, such as what is it?
Do we want lids?
And we can look at our path tracing.
You can look at these.
Now some of these may take a little bit to refresh and you may not always say, you know,
I can't quite see if this is a complicated material or not.
You're going to mainly do that within your editor and you're going to be able to look
at your optimization.
Optimization view modes a bit more efficient because some things which may have shader complexity
may not necessarily update and display here, but they definitely will inside of your editor.
But these are ways you can check.
So if for some reason you see that something isn't quite lined up, just keep that in mind.
That's something we are making it so it lines up a bit better.
But there may be moments where you will see that, hey, that's not as complex as I thought
it was, but the editor will tell you different.
You'll notice we can also change your shape here, any shape that we want to preview that
material in 3D space.
You can also, if you select, say this, say the item that you want in your scene, let's
choose this guy.
With that selected, I'm going to go to that piece of geometry, hitting that magnifying
glass with a folder, and it's now has that geometry selected in a content browser.
I can now click on the Cinderbock block here and it will load that into my scene.
And that's really helpful because now you can kind of get a one to one of the shape
object that has that material.
Down below, you'll see that we have a parameters area here that shows us some of the things
we have loaded and some of the organization we have in place.
We have our details here, which shows us how and what we use to choose how this material
is going to be digested with an Unreal.
Now you'll notice our blend mode is opaque, shading model is default, but you can change
these based on your needs.
Now we dive into this later in more advanced material classes, but you can do everything
from a deferred decal if you just want like a sticker effect on a piece of geometry.
There's a light function to project light, which we'll go over later in the class.
Volumes we'll talk about later in post process volumes, which allow you to change your
overall visual look using a loading the material in a post process volume.
You'll notice there's also blend modes.
We can choose mast for alpha, which we'll talk about later on to translucency, additive,
modulate in law.
All of these you can change based on what you want.
Like, hey, I want my alpha to look a certain way.
I want to look masked.
So we have like maybe some torn cloth, which we'll do later on.
You can choose these things depending on the look and the visual representation you need.
And there's also shader model.
This allows us to also choose such things as cloth, hair, eyes, as well as two sided
foliage in here and subsurface objects, which we'll also talk about later on.
So this gives us a lot of things to choose from.
Now, if you're noticing your shadows aren't correct when you move your light around,
you can also turn on, especially if it's a thin piece of geometry, two sided
geometry so that it is calculated correctly within the shader itself.
You can also use a thing called use material attributes, which we'll talk about later.
That allows you to encapsulate the final output here and redirect it so that you can
now make a thing called make attributes, which we'll talk about again later on.
And make attributes, it pretty much just substitutes this guy and turning it on
that tick box causes it to encapsulate.
You'll see that collapsing on itself and then it can redirect things as needed.
We'll turn that back on and get rid of this.
So there's a lot to choose from here.
I'm not going to get too much into buttonology because some of these are content
heavy as in context, I should say, as in having to do with particular classes,
which we'll cover it.
But I wanted to point that out.
You have a lot to choose from here.
So let's go ahead and talk a bit about the interface.
So here we have our save button as well as finding that material in the content
browser.
You say quickly clicked on that, took us there.
We can apply any changes if you want to test them out first.
I typically hit apply before I hit save because I may not like them or I may
suspect that there might be some errors if I'm doing something a little bit
complex and experimenting.
You can also search here.
You can search a particular node.
You say, Hey, I want to look for the albedo.
I can choose that.
Make sure I spell it correctly.
It'll show me where it's at.
And if I double click, it'll take me there.
Pretty nice to be able to do that, especially if you have a complicated
material you're having to deal with.
Now I can turn off the results here.
Stats will let me know how my shader is being processed.
If there's any, you know, if there's any heavy tasks I'm noticing, maybe I put
a lot of custom nodes in here.
This will show us some areas of instruction and also give you the errors
if they occur.
I'm going to close that too.
You'll notice there's a thing on the right hand here called palette and the
older versions of Unreal, this would be on by default.
You can turn that on, but now we kind of have it.
So it's like a shelf, which is kind of nice.
And you can go in here and look up anything that you need node wise.
And we have a lot of defaults you can choose from, especially if you're
jumping into the unknown and experimenting, you can play with these and research
them some more.
They're pretty great.
I do warn you, it's kind of addictive working with materials.
It's one of my favorite things to work with.
And if you watch some of my other videos, I get pretty deep into them.
It's a blast.
Now you can go home if you're too far away from the final execution string here
of our nodes, you'll take you right there.
Right clicking on the home button.
There's also a hierarchy here.
So you can actually take a look at some of these.
It'll take you to that concrete floor or another particular thing that's
actually connected to this parent.
It's just showing us everything connected to this parent material.
It just opened it up quickly for us.
We have a live update.
So we have preview material on.
We want to have that on.
But if you have real time nodes and other things that maybe some emotion
in movement, you want to test it out, you can have that on.
But by default, I typically just leave this on and should be fine.
You can clean up your graph.
And what that means is if I have any nodes floating around such as these guys,
I can say, Hey, man, clean up my graph, my graph here, and I'll clean it up
and it'll remove anything that doesn't have a connection.
I'm going to hit control Z.
I left those in there.
So if you wanted to play around, you can.
You'll notice here we have preview state, hide unrelated stats, as well as platform.
So you can actually choose what you're looking at your platform stats here.
And you can choose where you're going to be sending things out the door.
Is it Xbox is an iPad?
There's a lot of analyzing that can occur here.
And that's just based on your needs.
Well, that's it with this one.
It gives you a little preview of the interface.
We're going to talk a little bit more of it in the next video.
And we're also going to talk about how to organize things when it comes to working
within the grid.
Thanks again.